soy mujer orgullosamente mujer por mi
pensamiento por mi cuerpo por mi raza
por mi ser
soy mujer orgullosamente mujer y no
podría ser de otra manera palabras de
alicia guevara
dolor y falsas creencias
estos acontecimientos de dolor que trae
la vida
circunstancias de dolor que vienen
además acompañado de falsas creencias
como por ejemplo quien la mandó a ser
tan bonita
que al pobre y al feo todo se le van
deseos que hay unos que nacen con
estrella y otros estrellados que soñar
alto de harrison
circunstancias de dolor que dejan
cicatrices y cicatrices que a su vez se
convierten en lecciones lecciones que
está en cada uno
repetir una o mil veces
pues a mí me costó más de 10 años
empezar a entender que no era un porque
a mí sino para qué
a través de estas imágenes quiero
mostrarles lo que ha sido china a lo
largo de toda una historia aquí tendría
un año de edad y estaba repartiendo eso
será un beso para mi papá aquí estaba a
los 5 años en el colegio
aquí estaba con 10 años
aquí recuerdo mucho que ya estaba como
con muchos sueños y quería ser cantante
y actriz
aquí estaba en los 15 años
a mis 17
a los 20 fui madre muy joven fui madre a
los 15 años
pero aquí a los 20 estaba llena de
sueños e ilusiones
aquí también tenía 20 años
soy una potes y soy reconocida como la
primera sobreviviente de quemaduras con
agentes químicos en nuestro país no me
enorgullece ese primer triste lugar pues
que te quemen junto a tu hijo de tan
solo tres años ya tu hermana de 12
realmente fue muy muy difícil no tengo
ni siquiera palabras para expresar lo
que fue
pues a mis 20 años estaba llena de
sueños ilusiones estaba en el mundo del
modelaje y quería estudiar diseño de
modas pero todos esos sueños y esas
ganas de vivir esas ilusiones fueron
reemplazadas por múltiples cicatrices
por más de 30 entradas al quirófano más
de 70 procedimientos quirúrgicos donde
cortaban partes de mi piel para medio
arreglar otras no lo podía evitar la
tristeza desolación depresiones
angustias necesidades hacían parte del
día a día entre los 20 y los 30 más o
menos intentará sacar la cabeza varias
veces para intentar acceder a mis
derechos a los derechos que tenemos
todos a los que nos otorgan la
constitución pero cada vez que intentaba
rebotaba como pelota pues la
indiferencia era muy grande
toda esta angustia y todo este dolor
venía acompañado de esas falsas
creencias pero especialmente de una
quien la mandó a ser tan bonita eso fue
lo que me dijeron ese 28 de octubre de
1996 mientras quemaban no solamente mi
vida y mi humanidad sino prácticamente a
toda mi familia
en todo este camino
eso fue en el 96 les conté más o menos
hacia el 2004 me convertí en madre una
vez más
y tristemente para mí una vez la vio una
vez más la violencia llegan a las
puertas de mi vida y de mi humanidad
esta vez me dicen que el trabajo no
quedó bien hecho y fui violada y
torturada sexualmente de una manera
impresionante dejando huellas en mí de
una manera de verdad
recuerdo mucho que llore por días
semanas
meses
mi familia nunca se enteró ellos creían
que era una depresión post-parto
por este tiempo también conocía otro
caso de maría maría fue otra mujer que
quemaron con agentes químicos y ella
perdió a uno de sus ojos todo su cuero
cabelludo
su nariz parte de su rostro
y algo en mí me impulsaba más allá del
dolor y de todo eso que me estaba
pasando al levantarme aquí yo no podía
seguir llorando toda mi vida a que el
sol afuera seguía brillando aquí tenía
unos hijos de hermosos que estaban
tristes porque yo no era capaz ni
siquiera de sacarlos al parque
es allí donde entiendo que el dolor
existe la pérdida de un ser querido una
ruptura amorosa un mal negocio un
accidente una enfermedad del dolor
existe es real pero que el sufrimiento
que era una gran burbuja yo lo veo de
esa manera es como esta alfombra para mí
el sufrimiento es una gran burbuja en el
que me paso a vivir ahí para lamer me
las heridas
cuando yo entiendo todo este proceso
entiendo que maría me necesita que mi
familia me necesita pero que
especialmente china se necesitaba en ese
momento
por este tiempo y en la búsqueda de
todas estas respuestas y desee querer
dejar de llorar y querer dejar de ser
víctimas y dejar las culpas conocí a
sandor sandor es un chico que conocí más
o menos por el 2008 tendría unos 33 años
en ese momento desde sus 19 estaba atado
a su cama pues un día salió como
cualquiera de nosotros a departir con
sus amigos y dos balas impactaron su
humanidad una atravesó su médula ósea la
otra una de sus dedos uno de sus deditos
tetraplejia fue el dictamen final cuando
lo conocí ya llevaba varios años mirando
al techo como él decía pero tenía una
sonrisa maravillosa
y en el medio me imagino en su proceso
también empezó a mirar menos y por qué a
mí porque estoy acá ahí empezó a leer a
wer wenn sí a ver buen cine compartir
con personas y adquirió de verdad una
sabiduría que yo siempre digo que él
para mí fue un maestro espiritual
pues me obsequió uno de los regalos más
hermosos que me han dado la vida que son
las siete leyes espirituales del éxito
tanto tiempo después trascendió
del recuerdo sus hermosos y grandes ojos
verdes
esto es dedicado a ti mi sangre
las siete leyes espirituales del éxito
el universo no te está castigando el
universo no te está bendiciendo el
universo simple y sencillamente responde
a la actitud y a la vibración que estás
emitiendo
causa y efecto
en todo este proceso y en toda esa mano
de mocos realmente que llore y que hasta
me comí porque créanme que yo parecía no
sé era impresionante
un día me quise como como oye llena de
verdad
yo no era capaz de mirarme al espejo
pues mi mamá me trajo un espejo muy
grande recuerdo y me desnudé totalmente
me paré frente a ese espejo
y lloré seguía llorando todavía pero
esta vez de una manera distinta porque
allí empecé a reconocer cada una de esas
marcas y de esas cicatrices que me había
dejado la violencia
que me había dejado los acontecimientos
que me habían dejado las falsas
creencias pero que especialmente me
habían dejado mis actos
mis acciones
mis pasos en falso
pues es allí donde yo entiendo y empiezo
a darme cuenta que claro yo entré en
guerra con el mundo entero con el
universo con mi mamá con mi papá bueno
mi papá no porque bueno si con mi papá
porque me abandono desde chiquita yo
pero es que él me abandono es que él no
me ha dejado es que mis amigas ahora son
más bonitas que yo y es que mis hermanos
y es que nadie me entiende y digamos
porque me hiciste esto donde estabas
y esas culpas eso es lo que yo llamo el
sufrimiento que da en la gran burbuja y
está ahí metida en nadie me sacaba
pero cuando yo me paro un día y empiezan
todo este proceso y me hago la reflexión
o la pregunta de iu bueno claro si yo no
justifico la violencia nadie tiene por
qué venir a tocarte a dañar tu
integridad
tu humanidad
pero si hay una cosa maravillosa que me
empezó a pasar en ese tiempo y fue que
empecé a asumir las responsabilidades
que yo tenía cuáles fueron esas
decisiones en la vida que tomé para que
me llevaran al punto de haber sido una
víctima más en este tipo de violencia
claro no estoy diciendo que me lo
merecía eran y que tengo la culpa no
sino que tomé un camino un día en la
vida me metí acá una persona que no
había metido sabía que no me querían
sabía que había enemigos pero aún así
seguía ahí porque pues dios me cuida
siempre estamos dejando la
responsabilidad en los demás ha sido
maravilloso para mí en aprender a soltar
estas culpas y estas respuestas estás
culpas y asumir las responsabilidades me
siento mucho más feliz hoy por hoy me
siento mucho más capaz de tomar
decisiones conscientes porque como bien
lo dicen causa-efecto
causan la causa siempre tiene un
detonador y ese donador soy yo ese
detonador eres tu acción reacción y el
efecto es la consecuencia o la respuesta
que te deja cualquier pensamiento
cualquier palabra o cualquier acción que
tú tengas
no sé si ustedes han escuchado estoy
segura que si esa canción de alci acosta
que dice así no voy a cantar la letra yo
es la que dice y vamos los dos a la
noche se oscurecía y no podía ver yo
manejaba iba más de 7 prendí las luces
para leer seguramente las llevaba para
gas había un letrero de desviación el
cual pasaron sin precaución muy tarde
fue y al frenar el carro rodea hasta el
fondo
después dice porque se fue porque murió
porque el señor me la quito no soy dios
a más de 100 no lleva manos
o sea en serio
es lo que pasa en la vida con cada uno
de nosotros
tenemos un parcial mañana pero vámonos
de parrado
y al otro día perdió el parcial perdía
semestre así vez es que usted me llevar
un diario tenía que quedarme estudiando
no es que ese profesor nos
pero mire que hay una hay una anécdota
que tengo en mi vida yo soy esteticista
y cosmetóloga de profesión se nota
me encanta todo lo que tiene que ver con
la belleza de la ropa o en un montón de
cosas aunque no lo ejerce
la primera vez que fui a buscar trabajo
yo no
y mi hoja de viaje
la señora cuando me vio
eso yo casi que me voy hacía revilla de
para atrás cuando le perdona la señora
tuve un montón de años para echarle la
culpa a la señora por no ver vos 4 no es
que yo como vamos para atrás es que
publicita yo miré como me trataron
y haciendo esta charla me pasó algo muy
bonito preparando esta charla y fue que
yo estaba pensando en este tema de las
culpas así que ejemplos le traigo esta
gente dios mío para que entienda mejor
algo muy bonito a estos seres humanos
maravillosos y recuerdo mucho
ese día cuando fui a buscar trabajo y
hoy entiendo que la señora tenía toda la
razón claro no fue muy sutil a la hora
de decirme porque ya casi me suicidios
algo llevo pero no miren si hubiera ido
esta china que les está hablando y miren
les juro que hasta la gerencia me la da
es más hasta el modelo me pone
levantamiento de glúteos
[Risas]
en serio ese día yo llevé a la víctima
ese día yo iba con la con la porno
miseria que es un término que yo utilizo
porque desafortunadamente cuando somos
víctimas o cuando pasan muchas cosas en
la vida vivimos desde la zona de confort
en la gran burbuja del sufrimiento y no
alcanzamos a darnos cuenta que hay algo
más allá que hay algo que depende de ti
que así como el sufrimiento es una
opción cuando uno se va a comer una
hamburguesa que le dicen papas
agrandadas
suprimiendo adicional
mira qué bien de la sombra
es así de simple el día que lo entendí
créanme que me siento supremamente feliz
soy la directora y fundadora de la
fundación reconstruyendo rostros la
primera organización que existe en
atención a mujeres oa personas
sobrevivientes de agresiones con agentes
químicos he logrado o más bien hemos
logrado que salgan dos leyes de la
república dos protocolos de atención las
rutas de atención las guías la cartilla
al primer respondedor somos el primer
país a nivel mundial que registran más
agresiones con agentes químicos qué
tristeza donde el 87 por ciento de las
víctimas somos mujeres y donde el 90 por
ciento de los agresores son hombres
allí hemos hecho un trabajo maravilloso
han llegado las víctimas en la burbujita
yo ya como las identificó entonces
empieza un proceso pero mira si se puede
nadar recoger el cabello eso no te pones
una faja y eso que adivina y vamos a
buscar trabajamos a ver se puede lo he
logrado con muchas con otras todavía
sigue nadie en el lamento en la que hay
cada quien está en su proceso
la vida continúa soy una mujer
maravillosa soy una mujer madre de tres
hermosos hijos 1 924 andrés 1 de 22
jon y una nena de 15 años
vivo con ellos y con nieve con mi
perrito
eso quiere decir que soy soltera pero
estoy buscando saber
mentiras
soy supremamente feliz me encanta dormir
me encanta salir de fiesta me encanta
hablar con mis amigos me encanta ver
esas personas que tenemos a veces ahí al
lado al hermano a la mamá y que a veces
por estar metidos en el celular o están
metidos no vemos y ahí están
ese es el amor real
mi hijo de 22 sep con una compañera de
la fundación
yo mis sueños y como decía adriana ya
estando así como con las cicatrices y
todo también pude llegar al tema de ser
modelo estuve en una pasarela estaba en
dos pasarelas y ha sido algo maravilloso
porque no es la cicatriz es como tú te
veas como tú te ves te ven los demás
cuando las cicatrices de la violencia
trascienden en el empoderamiento y la
resiliencia de las mujeres
gratitud es una de esas desde algo
maravilloso para mí que me impulsa a
seguir todos los días
quiero contar una anécdota de esta foto
cuando a mí me quemaron y todo este
tinte me pasó
yo rompí fotos o sea yo me quedé sin
nada nada nada yo desaparecí todo en
estos días preparando esta charla me
encontré un civil de un vídeo que le
habíamos grabado esa foto me la tomaron
14 días antes de que me quemara
tenía un lunar y todo el mundo tenía que
ver con ese lunar es donar que tiene
'cielito lindo' puntas la trompa este me
lo cantan todo el tiempo
cuando oí esta foto eso fue el domingo
me acordé de roberto que como este
domingo pues estaba lloviendo esta foto
y me puse esto es un pantallazo del
vídeo y hoy
quiero llenar botes de 20 años pedirte
perdón
pedirte perdón por las malas decisiones
que tome
porque es el lunar aunque no lo no lo
puedo recuperar y esa sonrisa hermosa
que tienes no se puede perder porque si
estas cicatrices me han dolido tanto en
la vida pero hoy las pongo al servicio
de todos y todas porque sirve como
espejo hace algún tiempo llegó una chica
de octavo semestre hacer un trabajo de
la universidad
y yo le di la entrevista a todo el tema
yo les hablo les digo les hago reír les
hago entrar como inconciencia de oye
para dónde vas qué quieres
al final se fueron sus compañeros y ya
se quedó y llorando me dice gina tú me
acabas de salvar la vida yo me iba a
suicidar hoy
es ahí donde yo digo que no es un porque
a mí sino para aquí
[Aplausos]